so this is what i call it the trillion
dollar venn diagram success right uh i
just made that up but so you draw those
circles of your skills
and say okay well i'm now not like one
in a million i'm one in a billion right
or one in five billion whatever that is
and if you can convert that into some
kind of monetizable business thing or
whatever that's when magic sort of
happens so that's kind of thing number
one it's like what's your thing what are
your skills um and what drives ones
how much value will that intersection
create is two things
one is how rare is that intersection
whether it's two circles or three
circles or whatever how rare is it and
then the other one is
[Music]
so on the pod right now we've got
darmesh darmesh is the uh founder of
hubspot he's uh your technical title cto
right
that is correct
i see you more it means that uh that you
have to do the ad reads for your own
company today
why are we talking about hubspot you do
the ad reads
you tell people why we're talking about
hospital because you guys do a much
better job i am terrible at that i'm
terrible at the promotion side of things
but
the uh sean do you you're renting a
house right now
yeah and darmas you do not rent though
right
not anymore i did for a long long time
i'm a big believer in rentals as it
turns out but
i uh i'm staying in brooklyn for the
summer and i rent uh a furnished house
and it or apartment and it is so much
better than owning a place and having to
worry about stuff all the time it is so
much better
i i think i i'm about the renting train
i think now like i've kind of been there
but like i actually love it more do you
like it because sean you owned a place
in san francisco for like four years and
then now you rent again
way better in fact every time something
breaks i now just have joy to be like
let me call somebody else it's their
problem
their cost to fix they have to arrange
it they have to do whatever and i don't
have to think about it plus also in
california property taxes are like
insane or like in san francisco because
the the house price is so high so
you know
even if you try to do the calculation
it's so hard to beat just this annual
property tax every single time on rent
wait so dumbass if you if you had the
choice again i mean i i think maybe
perhaps you bought because like your
wife wanted to or your kids wanted to
but if it was up to you
even with the family would you
be a renter
if it was up to me yes um because
just the the decrease in maintenance and
wear and tear on one's psyche and soul
that ownership uh
you know bestows upon you is just not
worth it it's that's that's my thing
it's just like like i don't want to
worry about those things i want to i
want to get as close to like living in
the matrix as i possibly can right and
renting is a step closer to being in the
matrix we don't have to worry about
physical things and atoms and things
like that it's like that's somebody
else's problem how how many people in
your socio-economic like ballpark like
uh you know founders of multi-billion
dollar companies or people like you do
you think also rent because i think
that'd be a if it were a fair amount
that would be fairly shocking to a lot
of people but do you know a bunch of
people that are similar to you that
still rent
i know people that are similar to me in
terms of they would prefer renting
because i've talked to them about this
but almost everyone i know now once you
get a family once you have like other
things that you're trying to factor in
um for instance
uh you know one of the things my wife
loves gardening and loves having a yard
and that's kind of hard to do in a
rental um not that you can't do it but
it's
right
one thing that a guy told me who who's
similarly you know i think he's probably
got like a 10 or 10 or 20 million dollar
house he was like
it he's like renting is amazing until
you want until your wife wants a
specific house
and then once your wife wants a specific
house or in a specific neighborhood that
neighborhood like like higher end
neighborhoods have no rentals so you
just can't get into that neighborhood
which means you can't have whatever so
then you're forced into a different path
and so i thought you know it's a it's a
version of good problems to have so
we'll count it that way um all right
what are we what are we talking about
where should we start
well you have a few things left over
from the last episode sean i don't know
if we want to jump into some of those um
let's do one because i think you will
have a take on this so so have you ever
read i don't know do you know paul
graham by the way
i do
we're not best buddies or anything but i
do know of him i've met him yeah so he's
from boston right or cambridge
cambridge yep yeah so you guys know one
another
he wrote a blog post back in 2008 it was
october 2008 so this is like right after
the the crash
and it's it's just if you go to
paulgram.com bad economy um is the name
of the blog post and he makes this case
where he goes the economic situation is
apparently so grim that some experts
fear we may be in for a stretch as bad
in the mid 70s which is when microsoft
and apple were founded and as those
examples suggest like a recession may
not be such a bad time to start a
startup but he which you've heard before
but i thought there's one interesting
part where he goes i'm not saying it's a
good time either the truth is more
boring the economy doesn't matter much
either way for a founder starting a
startup and i actually thought that was
a really good point because i hear this
so much it's like i'll talk to kind of
young founders and they
listen to twitter and they listen to
podcasts and they listen you know they
listen to kind of these like a lot of
it's like you know vcs who are you know
also pandemic experts and also you know
you know macroeconomists
as well and so they hear and then they
they sort of start to adjust their plans
and their mental models and like their
room for everything it's like dude
if you're a startup you're like an ant
in this world does the ant care what's
going on with the presidential election
no like
you basically just need to build a
product you need to carry your little
piece of dirt it's like build a product
get a customer get 10 customers like it
doesn't matter if the economy is bad if
you can't get 10 customers it's not
gonna work anyways and so
i thought it was a great little blog
post talking about like kind of starting
a startup during the downtime which is
where i think we're about to or we just
officially entered a recession again so
yeah i was curious dharmesh do you have
any thoughts on that
yeah so my position is i lean more
towards kind of
paul graham end of the spectrum which is
i think it's either neutral that it
doesn't matter it's uh one of the things
you're suggesting uh towards positive um
and the positive elements of being in a
a kind of downturning economy or
recession is that things become
available that would not have been
available to a startup before like
talent uh it's like oh well there are
people sitting at meta facebook or
sitting at google right now that may be
reevaluating their lives or they may
have just been let go from a
venture-backed uh company that raised
200 plus million dollars right so now
you've got this um talent that's coming
on the market that might not have come
on the market before uh things that were
super expensive like buying google
adwords or certain marketing channels
because you have this glut of money and
a lot of venture capital
you know i think of venture capital is a
very efficient machine of turning like
money from lps into google adwords
revenue right that's uh they're just a
conduit between the two um and as
in a downward economy you're going to
get less of that kind of glut of money
flowing in which drives the cost overall
down for certain things that i think are
important to entrepreneurs so i'm i'm
generally net positive that and down
economy is actually a roughly good time
to start a startup for like the last 18
months or you know whenever like the
last 24 months when everything's been
booming i've my wife works at airbnb and
uh you know i've got a lot of friends
that work at obviously hubspot and all
these and sean was at twitch so we have
like some some perspective on how on the
salaries of big companies and i've seen
some of these salaries and they are
crazy crazy crazy crazy crazy as the as
like a leader and uh the biggest
shareholder of husband and you like see
these see these numbers are you thinking
to yourself like this like we can't
afford to pay someone like an
entry-level person 250 000 a year i
don't know how this is going to work
like what what's your perspective on
that when when these salaries are going
so high and now it's like a little bit
normal more normal yeah but as a startup
i mean you can't afford those salaries
anyway right unless you're one of those
kind of rare exceptions that has 50 plus
million dollars going out of the gate
which is uh very very rare and so you
know one of the things a founder has to
kind of get good at it's convincing
really smart people to do this
irrational thing which is join you in
your startup right and if you can't if
you can't do that if you can't make that
sale which is the most important sale
you'll make is being able to attract
people and then it's customers um it's
not going to work so you have to do what
you have two things um either recognize
kind of superstar talent and give them
something they can't get um because it's
beyond confidence it's like oh you'll
learn more here oh you're gonna do your
own startup someday this is the place to
get your startup mba because you'll be
exposed to a bunch of things you'll meet
your future co-founder of the company
those kinds of things um either you have
to do that or you have to say i'm going
to be really good at identifying
diamonds in the rough people that have
not made it uh to the 200 plus 300 000
plus dollar salary yet but they will
someday i caught them early in their
kind of evolution and so i can get them
there's that so it has to be one or the
other form of arbitrage otherwise
you can't play the game that's just not
uh i don't think it's viable i i i'm
doing uh when you're saying that it's
like resonating so much because it's
basically all the three things we just
talked about i'm doing it's like i
started the milk road in january this
year and so you know it's been it's
about to be six months or it's been six
months and um it's like here let me
start a crypto company right when crypto
crashes you know like 78 and at the
beginning ben even my co-founder ben he
was like you know um
the only thing i can see going wrong is
if crypto goes in a bear market i go
well crypto's gonna go into a bear
market like that's like one of the few
certainties of crypto is that it goes up
and down and when it does it is dramatic
in all both ways it goes from the
elevator is dramatic in both ways
and i was like you know so it's just a
question of like
do you what do you think that kills it
or do we just make it through like this
that's really all we have to think about
here
um so that was the first part of
starting in a bad economy the second one
on talent was i recently hired this guy
and he quit a
pretty well-known
uh venture-backed company that i think
it just raised maybe 50 or 100 million
dollars and he joined and
i talked to him a little bit before he
joined like he was thinking about doing
his own startup he had we traded a
couple emails nothing serious just he he
wanted me to use his product then he
took a job at this place all right
whatever i forgot about him then he
emails me and i shared this on twitter
he emails me subject line
i have made an irreversible decision
and i was like okay i got to click this
what's inside and he's like i just quit
my job and i think you should hire me
and i was like okay directed to the
point and he tells me why blah blah blah
and so i was like all right boom i'm
sold very bold approach i already liked
your hustle before this because when you
were hustling to try to get me as your
customer i was like this guy's good um
so okay let's do this and i made him a
job offer which was not like you know a
silicon valley job offer but the guy
lives in san francisco he was working
for a silicon valley startup so he was
like
oh dude that's like a 50 pay cut and i
was like
um and i didn't i didn't say this out
loud but in my head what i what i felt i
i told him i was like
that's what i could afford to pay right
now and like look you come crush it the
sky's the limit but like that's what i
can pay you right now uh sight unseen
and i said and in my head i was about to
tell him the the line that i had heard
from warren buffett you guys probably
heard the story but when warren buffett
goes and tries to work for his you know
kind of hero or whatever ben graham
and he's like you know i'll work for you
for free and ben graham goes your price
is too high sir which is which is the
truth which is the idea that you got to
shadow ben graham and work side by side
with him every day was you should be
paying for that if you really want to be
like a successful investor that's how i
felt and i didn't want to say it because
it's kind of arrogant but it's like dude
if i take you under my wing my team is
like three people if you become one of
those three and you're working out of my
he came to my house yesterday you're
sitting by me working out you know side
by side every day
like really i'm providing more value to
you than you are providing to me at that
point and like there's still a you know
i i i appreciate the value you bring but
let's
like the dollar amount is um
like
uh the salary dollar amount is not what
not the value you're getting uh and i
think he knows that intuitively and
that's why he said yes but like
uh that ben graham story always stands
out family
no no he's a young guy just graduated
from college
but
here's the thing i think people uh
couple thoughts on that one is
the salary slash compensation is just
one vector of value that you get from a
company that you join right another one
that you get is you get the learning
whatever it is that they get expose you
to another one that you get is a network
that you build while you're there right
there so there's all these other things
that also in kind of in aggregate and
maybe and i think it's common for people
to over index on the compensation or the
kind of current compensation um and
under index on other things that um and
then there's just the just raw emotional
value do you like being around the
people that you're around uh do you
enjoy the idea that you're working on
like is that you know those things
matter as it turns out um i have a fun
hubspot story so when we started on this
compensation thing uh you know ron and i
had to pick salaries for ourselves
something more than zero and so we
picked five thousand dollars a month
right it's like okay well that's it's
it's a number um
and uh obviously uh below market value
we've been out in the market for a while
and had worked in our lives uh so when
we hired employee number three
um we had to decide what we were gonna
pay them five thousand dollars hired
employee number four five thousand
dollars and so we just like okay if
you're here for the salary you're here
for the wrong reason right that that's
not why you're gonna join this motley
crew of uh folks and that lasted
for like a while it's like we and then
we and then it kind of has this inertia
built in where it's like okay well all
of us sitting in the room chatting with
you that we're trying to get you to join
the company are all paying each other
i'm paying ourselves five thousand
dollars a month now what do you think
you should be able to get when all of us
are making five thousand dollars of
course that doesn't last forever and you
have to
uh
what was the pitch at that time so it's
not like you know no offense to hubspot
but it's not the sexiest idea you're not
saying we're building the electric car
here you know like you didn't have that
going for you um you know you might have
had like a you know your own magnetism
which is like you know like for me i get
this cheat code because
like this guy he listens to the podcast
and this happens this podcast is a great
talent pipeline for us because
people will listen to it and over time
they just they decide for themselves
either i think this guy's a dummy and he
annoys me or i think this guy's smart
and i really like you know i'd love to
hang out with these guys i think i could
learn a bunch from them and so it
becomes an unfair advantage but you
didn't have that back in the day so what
was your how did you convince people to
do this five thousand dollar you know
lego block of uh salary building
so we cheated a little bit right because
um of the first eight people in the
company
seven of them
uh came out of mit sloan the same school
that brian i went to and we met in class
so it was kind of in-network kind of
thing it's like okay well it's just a
bunch of friends that sort of know each
other in network or whatever let's let's
go do this thing right and it's also
and they were
kind of far enough along in their
careers that they were not missing meals
or anything like that right they had
just gone to you know business school or
relatively uh good business school
and and so that was it like and then the
other thing and this is the
part there's equity but there's also the
like this is not that risky dude like
let's say this doesn't work out we end
up being chumps so the idea is really
bad three six months from now you will
basically be able to pick up where you
left off right there's like there's no
loss other than the opportunity cost of
those three to six months this is not
like a irreversible lifetime decision
that i've made this call and that's all
i'm gonna have to be able to do for the
next five or ten years um that was
enough it's yeah um what did things
change
how many people do you think um how many
people do you think at hubspot have made
like eight figures because of their
equity and once you worked with those
people for a long time and you're like
oh [__] like we the company went public
and like you don't need to work anymore
and and does that change the dynamic
um
it hasn't so i'll to answer your
questions uh i always have to there's
this little it only takes like a second
and a half for me to translate eight
figures into what is that actually so
that's ten million plus um yeah like
maybe
maybe five or ten million is like the
number where you're like [__] this i
don't need this job
uh
probably somewhere in the 20 to 30 range
if i had to guess of people that have
made that much um you know over 50 maybe
even 100 like millionaires in the seven
figure range uh but even when that was
happening right like well a couple of
things one is
it distorts it a little bit because as a
private company even though the
valuation from the last round or
whatever is x
uh the shares are not liquid right so
they're worth it but they're worth it on
paper they can't go out and actually
sell their shares so that's kind of
thing number one um and so it doesn't
even if they wanted to doesn't we can't
really change behavior you can't go off
and
um you know buy something with with uh
with your shares
so that's the number one the thing
number two is that uh we did have
like this kind of spree decor right it
wasn't really about the money it was
about winning it was about kind of
building something together and i um i
like to believe
that it wasn't even really the idea that
if we had taken that same early group of
20 25 people and parachute them into
some other company in some other
industry there's still software in sas
that we would have likely done
reasonably well as well i think it came
down to the people have good chemistry
they were focused on the right thing i
think we
um our early hiring policy was um to
hire
kind of smart people that get [__] done
that was kind of the the thing right we
want people that have high what we call
high wattage they were like measurably
smart if you had to have them take an iq
test we didn't do that but uh measurably
smart uh but there's lots of very very
smart people in the world but they have
this kind of predilection to action like
they could not help but like if they
found a problem they're gonna go try and
start solving they're gonna jump in um
you know feet first and they're just
going to do it or at first whatever the
phrase is and that was enough so we had
we made a deliberate decision not to
hire what we call press release hires uh
press release hires when you hire
someone and then you feel compelled to
issue a press release say oh hubspot
just hired the vp of sales from such and
such company whatever that has a 30-year
background in doing x
if we felt like we ever hired someone
that was worthy of a press release we
did it wrong right that's not the kind
of person we were looking for because
they may have done amazing things at
google microsoft facebook pick your
company of choice but the startup is
such a different context and you're
you're paying for these kind of
specialized set of skills that may or
may not be relevant uh arbitrage is
really really hard so we're
bigger on the
identified diamonds in the rough people
that are going to be big you know it's
like you're buying a stock early
um versus going after the folks that
already were
press release worthy so i think i uh
that's been my skill sean you've kind of
seen my journey i think my skill has
been finding the diamond and the
diamonds in the rough so we've had like
well sean and i kind of discovered one
another uh but then like there's steph
smith who's now at a16z we had trung
who's popular we've had a bunch of
people who went on and founded different
companies
and what i've always looked for
like i i purposely have looked for these
diamond the roughs because i was like i
can't afford you know to pay xyz so i
gotta hire this 24 year old who i know
will be a boss in like five or ten years
sam it's not just that you can't afford
them i remember once the hustle got to
the point where you could afford them
you were just kind of disgusted by the
concept of somebody making that much
money i remember you were just like how
much do you how much does this kid over
here work this like engineer at my
office and i'd be like i don't know like
whatever he's 150 170 you're like what
70 oh my god like this is uh you know
if if this person left would the company
fail no no not at all well it was like
this is crazy
that was ten years or that was the year
yeah so things have changed a little bit
uh but also like your people would show
up to work at like noon and i'd be like
what the hell man this guy like just
waltzed in and like you're gonna get
he's like he arrived right when they're
serving lunch uh but uh we've we've like
discovered some cool people and i always
look for a couple things the first thing
is actually this is from paul graham he
goes i like to hire animals like people
who like you're a little bit afraid of
and they're like uh just like freaks
where they work a lot i also work look
for people who are like weird so i
always want like weird people who have
like fairly extreme opinions even if i
totally disagree with their opinions i
really like that someone's like well
thought well well researched and has a
strong opinion on something but i love
like weirdos and eccentric people and i
have found that if you can at our
startup at the hustle we did a really
good job of like accepting weirdos and
letting them be odd and like we like
embraced it and i always found that to
be kind of like a
a uh we used to say you know let your
freak flag uh let your freak flag fly
and uh we're like you know i don't i was
like we'll have we had all types of
different people we we had uh just just
every type of like person we worked at
our company and they'd like that we like
embrace their odd they're kind of like
them being different
yeah we have something so we have you
know five kind of core values as part of
our hubspot culture one of them is is uh
remarkability or being remarkable and
what we mean by that is there's
something noteworthy they've done in
their past or there's something quirky
something different something that's an
outlier about them and it doesn't have
to be specifically business or whatever
even role that they're in but there's
like they're just kind of like off the
kind of main beat and that we've done
well with
those kinds of people we give them a
home kind of let them uh do their thing
and that tends to work out yeah so sam
had
weirdos and kind of like let your freak
flag fly you have the um
the remarkability have you done
something remarkable we had one at bibo
that was the same as we used to say we
hired degenerates it's like
intentionally a word that's usually
negative right like we hired degeneres
and what we said we would always ask me
fur khan we noticed this in each other
we were like dude we've gone through
these phases in our lives where we just
got really obsessed with something that
didn't have a clear payoff like it
wasn't the popular thing to be obsessed
with um like it wasn't the like cookie
cutter good thing to be obsessed like it
wasn't like grades in school
it would be like you know for kind of
got really into you know um
this video game and he's like yeah i
became like a top 100 ranked player of
this game and like it was a total like
you know in one hand i knew it was like
a waste of time but like i couldn't help
it i just loved it and i obsessed with
it i became the best at it and i just
wanted to win like so badly and at some
point i even stopped being about winning
it was just like i wanted to like get to
like the next level and and keep going
and i had i had done the same thing with
poker he had done it with poker also so
we kind of identified these
do you it's like hey do you go through
these periods of like three years of
deep obsession around some get
competitive like thing
and um and then when you do do you like
really like try to study the game and
figure out how to like what are the
loopholes in the game what are the rules
of the game you immerse yourself with
other players in the game because like
well cool our game now is just startups
and we would try to find people who had
some evidence of degeneracy it's like
yeah you come in at noon because you
stay up until four in the morning like
building that uh soundcloud player that
works like tiktok for no reason because
you're so annoyed that soundcloud
like is too slow in the way that they
develop things it's like other people
would look at that as like oh you're not
really reliable or very structured or
you you know why did you work on that
that wasn't even like the task at hand
whereas we would see that and we'd be
like oh all we need to do is just point
this guy's degeneracy at the right
direction and then we'll win and that
was like our mindset
yeah i i think of that as a kind of
borderline pathological obsession like
that's like once you attach yourself
whatever it happens to be right and what
our job is to kind of bring it just shy
of pathological where it's like kind of
harming themselves but it's like you
can't help yourself you're gonna like
just dig in and whether it's video games
or whatever it happens to be people that
have i don't call it a gene but to have
that trait um
tend to work out well in startups
because you're trying to attach yourself
to a particular thing to your problem um
the other thing i'm just as aware since
we're on the topic of talent i've got
this little mini framework works at
multiple levels of abstraction they're
like
um three kind of vectors of kind of
measurement of people one is that you
have the creatives and these are people
that start things they have ideas they
have 180 mile you know ideas an hour
kind of thing if you sit down in a room
with them uh then there are the so
they're the starters uh then you have
the completers those are people that can
make a list of like here are the things
that need to get done in order for us to
ship a product to do whatever um and
often those folks are at odds like the
the idea folks are kind of really
frustrated with the the completers that
are like i'm just trying to check a box
and make and it's like yes but i'm doing
this thing and it's not good enough yet
but you have that tension and that's
what brings in the third person which is
the collaborator and the collaborator is
really good at communicating is really
good at bridging gaps across departments
across individual people and kind of
pulling it all together
and usually you're looking for someone
that has at least some
like a nine or ten on one of those
dimensions
a seven or an eight another one and
usually very low on the third right it's
like you can have one for you
we're creative i'm on the creative side
i'm like yeah um
for sure
well but how that doesn't make sense to
me because you lead a 20 billion dollar
software company that and you've been
doing it for 20 years like and as a cto
like how on earth do you pull that off
and it's public it's publicly traded
which means you got to go through all
the [__] that like is the opposite
of creativity
yeah how do you how do you like well
like one thing you shared last time you
talked about those little like kind of
calculators or the little like kind of
growth growth tools that you had built
which was just like oh i was just
tinkering and i made this little like
page load speed test site and then or
whatever i don't remember the exact
example but you had built like three or
four of those that drove like a
substantial amount of traffic for
hubspot early on and like even now with
wordplay like you know you're just
you're still creating stuff even now
that yeah but we were just talking we
were just talking he's getting ready for
the earnings call and like that to me is
the opposite of creativity you know what
i mean that's like you're you have so
many you have such a narrow lane that
you could stay within that's like seems
so hard
yeah so i'll say this um i have done
everything in my uh
in my power
to reduce the time i have to spend on
things that i'm not good at right which
is the things that are kind of
non-creative not a part of that so i
don't have any direct reports which is
unheard of for a company that's you know
for a founder that has uh 7 000 people
in the company a lot of them on the kind
of product and engineering team which
presumably um you know the cto would
kind of help manage lee i don't do that
um
and so and the only meetings i go to are
where there's some creativity involved i
don't like to go to kind of status
things and updates or whatever it's like
i can read an email as well as the next
person um
so but yeah but there are things that
are non-delegatable that um one we
should we should probably talk about is
on my list of things uh so one is
earnings calls um another one is getting
on the public stages right so for
instance we have an annual conference
called inbound that you know the last
time it was in person had like 25 000
people in the live event right like it's
um it's big and i have to give the
keynote every year and i've been doing
it for 10 plus years now which i hate
and i'm bad at uh but that was one of
those because i'm founder that was one
of those non-delegatable things right i
couldn't say oh well we're gonna have
someone else to go do that because
you know in my role as founder i have a
certain kind of weight to me just by
virtue of the title um of being a
founder versus um someone else so sean
listen to this listen to this dharma
story in darmash you could fill in the
blanks as we go because you could decide
how much you want to reveal but there's
been a couple different times maybe
three different times i've introduced
dharmesh to a founder of a company who
was raising money
and
literally within five minutes he replied
and said i looked at the deck i'm in or
blank him out he dumbest you could
reveal if you want to say some of the
some of the times how much it was but
uh and he replied with i'm in just so
you know though i've got one rule which
is i always side with the founder um and
i'm always on your team but the downside
of that is like i'm gonna make close to
no time you didn't say it this way but
it's like i'm gonna make close to no
time for you or like you know like i
think you said it like i'm totally going
to be silent a silent partner i'm not
going to bother you which means if you
want to bother me i probably
you know i'm not going to talk to you
that much but that's like the
stipulations for taking my money if you
want to take it great do it i've seen
that happen three different times and do
you want to reveal how much it was or no
i i don't recall but um i will say this
i've made roughly i think a little over
100 investments now across my angel
investment
i won't call it a career but my
activities and
eighty to ninety percent um
i've never actually talked to the
founders or ever met with them um
over
the vast majority of my deals i make the
decision within 24 hours it's like
like i don't have time to go dig in to
do due diligence on some industry or
whatever it's like that's not the point
my point is not that there's only two
reasons i do angel investing um and it's
not neither of them are to make a return
um one of them is around living
vicariously through other entrepreneurs
i just like
i like that process um and this is you
know predates even starting hubspot and
the other one uh quite immodestly is
just bragging rights is to be able to
say five ten fifteen years from now it's
like because no one cares like how much
you invest when i was like oh yeah i was
in octa back in the day i was a stack
overflow back in the day i was like you
know first money on this company this
company this company uh and that feels
nice it's uh it's not such a
kind of magnanimous giving back to the
community it's purely like oh it'd be
cool to be able to
have been part of you know these great
founding teams that went off and built
great companies i really respect that
you said that part because i thought you
were gonna say
like um you know to support the causes
yeah i just you know just to foster
entrepreneurship or like you know
you know use the d word democratize
something something and instead you said
a true thing that i i think every angel
investor feels is like
it's awesome to have a notch on your
belt and be like yeah
i either i saw that or i backed that i
bet on that and it worked out and it's
awesome it's an awesome feeling it is a
perk of the job and it's a real one so
uh the fact that you said that to me
shows me that you are a real one darmesh
i'm i i'm what i refer to myself as like
a warm-hearted red-blooded capitalist
right so i have compassion it's not like
i don't like people i'm not a sociopath
um but i
i'm a capitalist it's like okay well for
instance this is going to sound
completely immodest but uh we opened
this door in the last episode so might
as well walk through it now is so last
episode we talked about kind of putting
a value on your time whatever it happens
to be and that anything that falls below
the line in terms of you can outsource a
delegate or whatever for less than that
you don't do those things right you
don't mow your lawn whatever if um and
so
i haven't uh i should recalibrate but
you know my number personally the one i
use just because the math is easier it's
like ten thousand dollars an hour like
that that's what if i were on the open
market i think i could i could make that
if that's well dude i would have thought
higher i would have thought
i think it would be like 50 or 100 000
an hour maybe like i mean way higher
one could make the case but i couldn't
make my point without having to make
that particular case okay let me ask you
a question
to make it real so uh you
buy something you book a plane ticket
it's like whatever
it didn't work out or you deserve a
refund but you'd have to go chase it
down do you just have somebody who
you're like this is my chief of staff my
ea that like i just say you do it or
you're like hey it was two thousand
dollars but it's below my hourly rate
i'm not gonna do it i just eat the loss
and move on i don't do it because even
delegating then requires some follow-up
requires some explanation and they're
gonna apologize because they could only
get half back or it was only a credits
like i don't i don't care i just
honestly don't care um and so and back
to the investment thing so let's say you
know my when i started my average
investment rate was we'll call it a
hundred thousand dollars give or take a
little bit it's grown considerably since
then but if i spent like five hours
doing due diligence or having founder
meetings or whatever i basically
doubled their valuation or have my
investment amount right because like not
only did i put cash in for which i'm
gonna get shares but then i put another
50 000 or 100 000 worth of time in just
in the due diligence which is easy to
kind of run up that bill
it makes no mathematical sense why
people would do that right it's like
okay do you really feel like you're
going to and the reason they rationalize
and this makes sense is that if you
really believe that as a result of
spending that time on the margin you're
going to make better investment
decisions you're going to pick better
companies you're going to do these
things
and maybe for the first hour to list an
early stage startup there's just not
that much diligence to do right like
what are you going to dig into it's like
like the idea you don't you like the
founders or you don't move on
our software is the worst have you heard
of hubspot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but hubspot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous i
think i love our new crm our software is
the best hubspot grow better
or the the other part that's obvious but
worth saying out loud just in case
people are like well then why are you
doing this podcast well you also just do
things you like
those are the things that you don't do
you don't put a dollar amount on because
you enjoy them and therefore it is not a
cost to you it is like a you know a
benefit to you so so yeah if you love
gardening then you garden you don't put
a 10 000 an hour mark on it is that fair
for you that's how i think about it at
least that is fair and so what i solve
for is i like to solve for
it's because it's a little bit of a
squishy term it's just raw impact i like
scale so if you folks were a much
smaller blog let's just say it's like oh
i'm going to reach 50 people as a result
of this and i have ideas that i think
are worth sharing um and it was smaller
i'm like
and and it's not like oh i don't get up
out of bed in the morning unless there's
at least you know ten thousand people
like if this was morning bruce podcast
then
amplify my time right to what little
time i have left on the planet what
things that i know
um so i'm always looking for uh to do
things at scale like how can i find a
way
let speaking of things at scale let's
talk about this thing because like on
the surface this thing that you recently
did like a year ago is incredibly silly
and not worth your time but basically i
think a year and a half ago whirl is it
like a game that an online game is like
a word game that that went viral you
built a thing called the word play is it
wordplay.com it's wordplay.com right
uh by the way you buy domain name so you
bought the hustle.com for us you bought
me
copythat.com thank you for that um i
forgot to say thank you in person but uh
uh so you buy like a lot of amazing
domains but you have wordplay.com and
did you tweet that it was getting seven
million users a week or three what was
the number what so the
i just went and checked the numbers okay
so just to kind of
place the timeline in frame uh so
november and december of last year 2021
is when wordle took off and january is
when it really kind of hit it's i think
close to its peak
and that's roughly when the new york
times acquired wordle
um and a couple of things kind of i mean
it was fine i think it was um
a great outcome for josh wordle but
there were things that were kind of
bothering me that were limitations in
the game and i was an avid player of the
game
um and now it's like okay well the new
york times has bought it there's no way
anything's going to happen for like
years if ever so that was kind of thing
number one uh thing number two like it
was uh it had been a while since i had
launched like some simple free thing
publicly uh i hadn't gone through the
process and there were other things i
wanted to learn it's like oh i want to
learn more about vercell and xjs and
typescript and things like that so it's
like okay well this is a
excuse and then that intersected with
the third thing which was like the
dominant variable in the equation is my
son was taking a python programming
class he's 11 right he's going through
this process
and for him um
it's still very abstract he's learning
programs he enjoys everything involving
technology and screens but it was
abstract so on a saturday night i said
okay well
let me build something and python
happens to be my language um
build something so he can see because he
plays world he knows the game
and so
i started on a saturday night with a
deadline for sunday that i'm gonna
launch something with him tomorrow we're
gonna have google analytics on it so
we're gonna launch it i'm gonna launch
it by tweeting it and so he know he
knows what social media is right he's um
you know uh so i'm like oh we've got
this thing that didn't exist yesterday
i wrote the code over the course of last
night in python the language that you're
learning and we're going to launch it
and now you can see users coming in
right you can see this and so now what i
want him to have in his head is that
when he has through the course of his
life as he encounters problems that are
solvable with software which is a lot
like it's actually tactile for him it's
like oh i don't know i don't have the
skills right now to do what your dad
just did but i know it's possible i know
it's possible because he did it in the
span of 24 hours right so if i want to
go off and build a video game i want to
go off and build some tool for my school
i want to build some social network for
my whatever it is
it feels like now it's it's more
approachable for him he's got years to
go before he'll get to that level but um
anyway so those three things sort of
came together and so we launched it
on that sunday this is i think in
february or so give or take
and since then it's had like 45 million
games have been played uh nine and a
half million people have come through it
um
any given moment in time right now for
look at the google analytics should be
two three thousand people playing like
right now um
which
how did it get so much traffic where did
the traffic come from well it helps i
have a social media following right i've
got a million followers on linkedin i've
got 300 000 on twitter so there's that
uh there's some
that that's that's a lot but that's not
i wouldn't have thought that yeah yeah
it's not enough for that is it how many
users you think got from that
um
in the early days
was it big right off the bat like the
first week was it big i know the first
day probably a bunch of people checked
it out but like i'm sure you posted it
and that was the big surge so what was
like the first week roughly do you
remember the first week was probably
maybe 50 to 100 000 so it was it wasn't
a lot but it was something uh but that
means that once you kind of get into it
this is the
you know kind of power of iteration is
that oh well one of the things that i
found missing in the original wordle was
that it was a single player game like
you played and you played once a day and
that was it uh so two big changes that
we made in wordplay one
was it was unlimited play you didn't you
didn't have to play just once a day and
two it it allowed you to challenge your
friends so you could say oh i just
played this word i solved it in four
turns here's my score and send literally
a simple link to anyone or a group on
and this happens
tens of thousands of times right like
someone will take a link they just play
they're really proud of their score
and then their family they can post it
to their whatsapp group uh they can post
it their you know wherever they want and
say i invite you to like beat my score
kind of thing um
and so that's the viral element and so
then as more people play you can unlike
track that as you might have as a google
analytics event and say how many people
how many times are people clicking that
share button and issuing challenges to
other people and so that once you can
kind of get into something where there's
a compounding effect on the user base so
as a user base grows um and so now the
thing i'm fighting though right is that
so that's happening that's going well
but then the interest in wordle in
related games is waiting because
everything has it's kind of peak and
it's uh and it's ebb um
and so but
it's been an interesting exercise so on
the kind of learning path one of the
things i hadn't done in a while is like
okay well what's traffic actually worth
let's say i had to make a living on this
thing or make the company quote-unquote
or project profitable so i put google
adsense on it which is the easiest thing
to do and discovered that
like
if i weren't bothered by the fact that
there would be two ads on the main game
board page if i were solving for
monetization it was like thousand
dollars a month
uh in google adsense wow based on the
traffic yeah wow i thought you were
gonna say way less
yeah i thought he's gonna say like 500 a
month but 90 grand a month and you're
you only have your only costs are
hosting right
yeah and and my time
right and
first of all sean go to wordplay.com and
then go to like the about page his about
page is incredibly well written it's
wonderful copywriting it's wonderful uh
you've got a wonderful voice it says uh
i'll just read the first sentence but it
says why would you do this
or the better yet why would i do this
that's a really good question
my wife asked me the same question and
then you like go on to explain why it
just you you're you're quite a good
writer for also being like this amazing
engineer typically those things power
writing course that sean put on you know
that right it's like i'm not right
around here with my alumni
[Laughter]
i like to say i taught darmesh
everything he knows even before he met
me i somehow taught him all that good
stuff before he built hubspot
what uh what are you so this is making
90 grand a month maybe or about what do
you is it it could it it's not right
there's no advertising
i turn ads off because that's
the point and people are asking is like
darmash why do you have ads on this
thing and like
to learn like it's like i've learned
what i needed to learn so i can
was was tweeting and linkedin posting
this on linkedin the only way you got
users what do you think this could sell
for right now and is the is this the
biggest side project you've ever created
our buddy tried to buy it silly tried to
buy it off you
did he really
he he tweeted out he's like i'd like to
buy this off you i've you know i've
built mobile games before you know he
was like semi serious at least i don't
know i don't know if you talk to him or
not but i did
what do you think you could say what do
you think like if you cared what do you
think you could sell it for
two or three million dollars maybe right
now that um let's say the ad revenue
would go down to like 50 000 or
something like that because i haven't
turned google adsense in a while that's
600 000 a year apply a 5x multiple uh
so somewhere between two and ten million
dollars would be my guess if i like if
that's what we're solving for so
and um is this the was was posting it on
linkedin and twitter the only way that
you got users or did you do some other
weird hacks i had my blog had my it's
like i'm a big believer in like you know
what folks call like the flywheel
there's all these little things that are
attached to the flywheel right it's like
oh well linkedin helps a little bit puts
a little energy twitter does a little
bit and i have my blog and the email
goes out and there's like things that i
sort of do
um
yeah so
it helps but it's like the hardest part
is that cold start problems like how do
you get your first hundred thousand
people a hundred to a thousand people
and then it's a matter of like tracking
the retention rate on those users do
they come back the other thing that's
been interesting about wordplay as far
as the lesson learned
um is that you know when it started the
average time a user spent according to
google was roughly four minutes um on
the game okay um in the early weeks and
now that number is at 14 minutes is the
average time a user spends um you know
across however many thousands of users
come in a given day so right what uh and
is this the biggest side project you've
ever created
uh depends on how you measure it um so
technically no not in terms of just like
raw traffic um i've built graders and
things like that before that uh have
done better but what what have you built
that what side project have you built
outside of hubspot that gets more
traffic
like clearly because it was a game had
it been anything other than a game i
would have rationalized some way to
bring it into the spot umbrella because
i like to have
like all my eggs in that basket uh but
just given the the circumstances here
didn't really make sense um and even now
like i'm thinking about uh doing a uh
kind of a marketing and sales related
edition of wordplay right it's like oh
the entire list of words or uh do it
based on more tech companies like okay
do you know the the players in the space
kind of thing and then you can get
sponsorships or whatever anyway but um
yeah website greater was the
this kind of a project where it was like
a free i'm
i really like low friction
things that people can come to the
website and this is why my son and i
were chatting yesterday is where i'm
we're looking at flutter this new
development environment and language um
well darts the language but flutter is
the
uh the app framework for building mobile
apps across ios and android and things
like it's what the cool new kids are
learning and he's like no why would i
ever want to build a mobile app that's
like something people have to download i
have to get approval from you know apple
to kind of post my like i i want to like
just do it like immediately he's got and
he's right just like okay anyway so
that's the word play story it's been
it's been a lot of fun i've um
it's hard to know with these things like
like where the road leads like wordplay
itself may or may not kind of connect
back to other things whatever but the
things i've learned through it
i think will it's like okay well here's
what it takes to build this kind of
thing it's like okay well then i'm using
it to uh play around with community it's
like okay can i take the word play user
base
what are things they care about and
build a community around wordplay using
one of the existing kind of community
platforms um and and see if that's a
thing right it's like okay if you could
aggregate people with like interests
um that in itself has value and i wanted
to send you something that kind of self
runs but we'll see if you were uh
i'm gonna ask
darmesh if sam had built this as a side
project and he was at the same point
you're at right now
what would you like kind of advise him
to do if it was sam's project and you
were just kind of an outsider said oh
that's really cool you did that
and it sounds like you've kind of
reached this point where you don't
really have a direction of where it's
going to go next what would you kind of
tell sam
um decide what you want to do which is
okay do you want to like take this to
the next level and you turn into a 100
million billion dollar business uh you
know spit it off or decide that it's
just going to be a personal project
and just like my personal blog is that i
made that decision it's like i'm not
going to try and monetize and hire
employees i'm not going to do any of
those things right it's going to be
and my son will continue to act as out
of product um because he's the one that
tests the thing every morning um and we
play tournaments every evening that's
the big new feature that's coming out is
the multi-round tournaments uh by the
way in terms of like
i think half of what i know sean i
learned from you the other half i
learned from from nfm right it's like so
one of the things around chess.com which
you guys talked about which i've been a
a member and player on for ten plus
years i knew of the site but then you
think about wordplay as like okay well
this is chess.com but for word game
enthusiasts versus chess enthusiasts and
then which is
as a reminder to people chess.com is
like a huge business like like
multi-billion dollar evaluation we
talked about this when we talked about
chess also which was what other things
are like chess and we had said sudoku
and we had said i think we had said like
a scrabble or whatever uh word is
yeah
i think they're almost as big if not i
think it would be i wouldn't be shocked
if it was bigger than chess i wouldn't
be shocked i would i would be more
shocked if it was like a tenth the size
as the chess enthusiast audience um i
would guess it's like in the range and
there's very few games that are in the
range and so that alone makes it an
interesting comp um in that sense
so so the lessons you draw from
chess.com right which is a relatively
straightforward is you have like a
rating system right you have
leaderboards and scores you have
challenges you have social connections
where you make your friends on chess.com
so you can invite like it's all the
things right these are uh
very easily translatable into other
games like we're playing um so anyway so
we'll
pick and choose as well i'll give you
one little feature i think would be cool
because uh leaderboards are always this
problem in general where uh
like
leaderboard's cool for the top 10 people
and then for everybody else on earth
it's like oh great i'm player number
three thirty nine thousand fantastic
right yeah uh and so there's all these
like if you i kind of studied this once
i was like who solved this problem and
there's really three models that work
one is more like chess uh and and games
do this they create a rank system so
it's not your number 80 000 in the world
because that doesn't mean anything but
you go from bronze to silver to gold to
platinum to master to grand master and
like you you just compete to get your
own level up within that to get to your
next badge and that's a karate belt the
karate belt method let's call it then
there's the next one which is
your social rank matters when it's with
people you know that are either your
friends your school your city something
like that so you can kind of hack a
proximity based thing and then the third
one which i think is somewhat
interesting which is
it doesn't even matter what my rank is
but there's something cool like if i go
to workplace right now i feel like i'm
alone in this experience i don't know
that there's 3000 other people solving
this right now
and also i don't know i bet you there's
like
some celebrity that plays wordplay every
day right like i bet you like i don't
know mila kunis plays this every day and
i think there's something really cool to
like sort of like a stars they're just
like us vibe of like if i kind of knew
that that x-known people have solved it
for today that's just kind of
interesting and it's kind of like you
know makes them more approachable so i
almost wonder if there was like a little
feature like that where if you're a blue
check tech person you could kind of like
auth in and be like i either solved it
or failed today and you could just have
that as a little board uh anyways those
are my three random features that's a
good idea the one thing's and i don't
it's not surfaced on the on the pro this
is a really good idea but uh one thing i
do have is in the comments there's the
there's commentary so as you're playing
the software will kind of give you
little kind of sometimes snarky
sometimes fun messages sometimes data
it's like oh you're one of the few
people that's ever guessed this
particular word that's not a very common
word to use congrats good for you or
this is the thousandth time you've used
this particular word uh points for
consistency um so there's this kind of
running commentary but i like the idea
of like just kind of front loading it's
like here's a number of people that
solve this game i give you stats at the
end of the game it's like oh only 14 of
the people or players solve this
particular word and it took them on
average seven point i mean uh 4.7
guesses so yeah
can i throw two more at you uh this is
now my my future brainstorm for you uh
if you've ever played there's nothing
more there's nothing more than like an
entrepreneur there's nothing more than
like a person who has no stakes saying
hey have you thought of have you thought
about have you thought about this
why haven't you done this yet there's
nothing less entertaining on a podcast
than me telling you features for
wordplay but [__] it's our podcast
if you ever played candy crush they do
this thing which was they make they uh
so steaks steaks matter a lot in stories
or any kind of like adventure um and so
like you know if you open up a pack of
warheads and you see a black one oh
that's the really crazy one
candy crush does this in their games
where if you start a level it says this
is nightmarishly hard or this is a you
know medium hard or whatever so i'd like
to see that in the wordplay when i come
into every day i'd like to know if this
is a nightmarishly hard puzzle or if
this is just okay it gets me amped up
from my play that's a really good idea
combining that with your tiering idea
and then we can move on but so imagine
we had a tiering mechanism that you go
from bronze to silver to whatever to
ninja level um you know right now when
you start the game you get a random word
that
and other people get random words as
well and there's a daily word um that
everybody plays together but imagine
that like as you move up the rank it
gets harder it's like now you're a level
that few have achieved let alone solved
right it's like no one even gets here
you're here um and then you do things
for streaks like okay well you're the
first person to have solved like 50
games in a row at this tier or something
like that i think that'd be fun so one
last one i think you'll like which is
um you are a fan of crypto and i think
you would if you like the crypto ethos
and i think if you could advance the
cause of crypto that would be like a win
for you personally um
so
we gave out this milk money grant that's
like milk for the milk we gave out like
a bunch of money to people just to build
whatever they want and one guy this guy
dave he built this thing that was like a
wordle game but it was with crypto which
was just you play wordle as is but if
you solve it you could win like one
matic like a tiny amount or like then he
was like playing with different ideas
he's like oh there's actually 100 matic
jackpot for the day and like only
winners are eligible for the jackpot you
might you might get it or you might not
and so you got a bunch of people
connecting a wallet so i think what you
could do is you could actually just add
that into wordplay which is by the way
there's a
100 a day prize paid out in matic or
whatever um all you got to do is create
a little wallet here and like you might
win and so i think a bunch of your avid
players would create a crypto wallet
where they might not otherwise so you'll
onboard new people into the world of
crypto you can create a dead simple meta
either funnel them to metamask or create
a dead simple crypto wallet that will
become like a the play to earn
uh crypto wallet you know for the future
anyways that's uh i will i will now stop
talking about a good idea yeah by the
way i
so i actually added the ability to
connect your um
connect your diesel wall to your
ethereum wallet um to wordplay um and my
idea at the time was
instead of turning ads off i'm gonna
make that the pot and so as ad revenue
accumulates until the next payout
whatever it happens to be and then it's
like oh the top 10 winners are going to
get this distribution and let's start
over again so not to make money but
we'll have money coming in through
adsense and then we'll kind of write a
sustainable play to earn game that's
awesome yeah that would be amazing
so let me uh sean
this is
uh an interesting topic but i understand
there's like laws and sec stuff around
what you can i cannot say darmesh just
tell me i feel like you can't but
basically i think it was in late may i'm
looking at now in like may 25th or
something like that um
sean i don't know if you saw this but
like there was headlines that said like
darmesh
uh cto co-founder of hubspot buys
hubspot shares and i think it was like
was it 10 million dollars it was it was
a pretty substantial amount
it was over three i forgot the exact
amount is but
it was millions of dollars and then
suddenly like
the stock like the next day like went up
because it was like oh man dartmouth
like this insider bought it he uh like
he has faith in the company that was a
pretty that that's a pretty cool move
when you're doing something like that
what is your thinking like are you
thinking like um like is it part of you
like i just want to prove to the world
that i'm brave is it part of you like oh
no this is just undervalued like they're
they're foolish uh it's i mean like what
what's your what's your motivation there
um
it's exactly what you said which is uh i
just thought the company was undervalued
given the long-term potential and i've
done this before i did it a couple years
ago um and i bought a bunch of shares i
think even more at that time like at 125
a share right i'm like okay well and
this is when hubspot stock had dipped
over the ensuing um i mean the pre-or
prior two or three months i'm like i
understand the market's more like it's
but this doesn't make any sense like it
you know hubspot stock to me was worth
more than um at the time 125 um turns
out i was right um and so it's it's a
similar thing it's like and it does
signal belief in the company right it's
but it's what i it's what i believe and
there are regulations around and you
know people ask like well why did you
you buy at that time as it turns out it
was the exact window of time that i had
to wait a certain period since my last
transaction um to when i could buy in
the day that i was eligible to buy i
bought it's like okay the price is low
enough i still have conviction that um
over the long run
buying with money that like where does
three million dollars come from let's
say isn't that just stock you previously
sold that you now were buying or like
it's like you have some other huge side
right yeah
yes yes
or can you can you take a loan against
your hubspot shares to buy more like
there's like 100 things you cannot do
that's one of them
wow no i think uh i saw that the other
day and uh you've done you've made a few
decisions like every once in a while you
do something and i'm like oh this guy is
nutty in a cool way and that's not
exactly nutty but it's like
a pretty bold move i i thought it was a
pretty cool move and i saw that and i
was wondering what was going through
your head when you did that because
what's the psychology like when uh i
don't know hubspot stocks like
i'm just rounding i think it's down like
40 maybe 50 something like that from the
all-time high like during the
the last kind of the peak of the peak
last year or whatever
um
and so you know we come on here
sometimes and i'll be like uh all right
guys you know you know sam will be like
dude how are you and you lost a bunch of
money today i'm like yeah yeah i lost
like a million dollars today and like
you know
ethan's down and i'm i'm down a million
dollars i'll share my psychology of like
dealing with this this travesty of a
loss or whatever and i'll be like yeah
you know here's how i think about it
you play that game at like a thousand x
higher stakes where like you know more
like
500 million yeah exactly i'm losing 500
000 you're losing 500 million or
whatever something crazy like that
what's what's your psychology like i
don't know like
i think you know what question i'm
trying to ask even though i i don't have
the word how does it feel to be half a
billion dollars is what you're asking me
or dad how do you deal with that and
like
yeah go go is that how much you lost you
think it's more than that but yeah who's
counting
he's like this podcast is more fun when
we were talking about wordplay
actually fine like i'm i'm not really
and i'm not just saying this uh but
it's true
it does not phase me like one bit
because the reality is um
it does not change my life one iota
right other than like okay well
it impacts you know hubspot employees
and children i get that but in terms of
me individually like nothing changes
right like i wasn't off planning to buy
smile small islands or take over
governments or something like that um or
by twitter right i was not i didn't have
any of those kinds of plans and so
absent those kinds of plans um like i
feel sorry for the non-profits that i
would have invested in but you know
my wife continues to invest there's you
know we have uh plans to do the
philanthropy we want to do and so it's
like okay well i still wake up every day
then do the same things i did before and
i'll look at the wordplay things and
respond to user emails or what's i can
do my hubspot stuff it's like okay like
what's really you don't even have
you don't even have the self-talk in
your head where you kind of need to like
because for me when it happens i'm like
you know i have a instant reaction as i
go look at a chart or a price or
whatever and then i give myself a little
self-talk and i'm good like it'll last
17 seconds but i do have those 17
seconds it sounds like you don't even
have those 17 seconds because you're
like well
i've already been over this before in my
head at some point in my life
it doesn't
let alone the self-talk the self-talk is
one thing let alone like that but and
then there's also this other thing that
you and i have sean which is like it if
the markets are [__] for a year or two
like we will change our day-to-day
actions like you know we may not
buy x y and z or like we might you know
we're not to that point where it's like
it doesn't matter major cutbacks at the
puri household right now major cutbacks
yeah it's like
we'll maybe change behavior but you
don't even change
i laid off my son yeah
they change in the other direction right
so as the market has dipped um
my kind of average check size has
actually gone up i've made bigger bets
and things because i think valuations
are starting to adjust
you know slowly so i think they're
better deals now um good entrepreneurs
starting companies um so
but overall like the psychology of it
has just
just does not like have any impact and
like over the long term you know um i
didn't make this up but
is is that the
you know the valuation of a company
which is like the market price um will
oscillate around the value
right and value is like the revenues you
have the products that you build what
are you actually doing um you know for
your customers and so that
you know if our revenues have dropped
off you know before something if
something like that would happen that'd
be a different story but it's like okay
well that hasn't changed we are the same
business today if not better than we
were three months ago six months ago um
and the valuation over time will kind of
self-correct some of the things i like
about the market um is that i think
things will kind of wash out and we'll
see yeah and a lot of hubspot's
customers are kind of like you know
medium-sized let's say businesses um
so do you like do you spend much energy
being like okay where is the economy
going what's going to happen to my
customers which will have some knock-on
effect of like what's going to happen to
our business
do you care spend energy there because i
find myself for the reason i ask because
i find myself
sometimes going down these rabbit holes
of like okay what do i think's going to
happen then part of me is like well does
any of that really matter or affect me
or you know is this energy useful or is
this just sort of nervous energy that
i'm wasting thinking about this stuff do
you think is hubspot is that customer
base even how many customers does
husband have like 130 000
like
i think when i sold it was a hundred
thousand or just crossed a hundred
thousand in the grand scheme of things
the one the reasons i sold i'm like well
hundred thousand customers that's like
kind of a lot but that's not that much
uh i was like the market's way bigger
than a hundred thousand people who would
want to buy this and so is is a hundred
thousand or 150 000 whatever it is is
that number even big enough to have the
needle move significantly when the
economy is [__]
uh on a on a percentage basis like it's
um
i'll answer it this way so i'll answer
the first question then we'll move the
second one which is you know do i spend
time thinking about this do i do
anything about it the answer is yes um
at hubspot we will try to model out
here's here's the impact we think it
could have on our business uh but
there's two sides to it there's the kind
of defensive side of it it's like we
want to make sure
um that we have enough cash in the bank
to weather the storm we don't know how
long the storm's gonna last and we have
models for how um you know how long it's
gonna last how deep it's going to be
those kinds of things as far as impact
but then the other part which is to me
much more exciting which is okay given
what we know
what can we do to capitalize um on this
crisis right this is what's happening
right now what can we do to make this
net positive for hubspot and we had
something similar happen in 2008 at the
last uh spot was much earlier so things
uh we did even when the pandemic started
well the things we did is like oh
there's lots of uncertainty businesses
are struggling everyone's kind of
batting down the hatches and so we said
okay we're going to give even more value
we're going to um
for our partners we're going to front
them the cash for the revenue we know is
coming over time because cash is a is an
issue and we had a bunch of cash on the
balance so we did things that kind of
made us stronger and helped our
customers and um and so we're looking
for those same kinds of opportunities
it's like okay now that everyone's
kind of looking at the p l and looking
at all their line items or whatever is
can we benefit from this because
hubspot in some ways is counter-cyclical
was like okay well instead of buying the
big incumbent and spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars maybe now people
that might not have considered hubspot a
year ago would now consider it because
they're more value conscious now than
they were historically um yeah so
when you were starting the company so
like there's a there you know if you
just look at the math there's a world
where hubspot in the next five or ten or
who knows how long can be worth like a
hundred billion dollars which is you
know one of the biggest
top 200 or something companies in the
world when you were starting the company
did you have a number in your head where
you're like man i think this i think
this could make a hundred million
dollars a year or i think this might be
a billion dollar company or was it as
big as man i think this could be worth
tens of billions
we didn't have a specific number in our
head but we had um
i'll say comparables for lack of a
better term which is okay there are
successful software companies that have
done similar or related things either
they're in the same market or um in the
same target customer base
that achieved it it's like okay well and
this is what we told to vcs at our pitch
we're like okay we're not
we think at the time we were just in
marketing software so here he was i'll
give you the first 30 seconds of the
pitch is that in the history of software
no one has ever really built a 10 plus
billion dollar household name global
brand marketing software company had
never been done amateur was the greatest
one at the time with a billion half
dollar um you know price tag at the time
and we're like and the reason people you
know companies have not been built in
the marketing tech spaces because
marketing is an arts and crafts kind of
discipline it's about the shade of your
logo and you're outsourcing a bunch of
creative stuff whatever but it's not the
kind of problem software solves
and our belief was that marketing was
increasingly turning into
the kind of thing software does solve
lots of data coming in you're trying to
make decisions around all this stuff
this looks exactly like an industry that
software can help with and so our thesis
was that someday someone will build a
hundred 200 500 billion dollar software
company that's doing the thing we're
trying to do and we said it might as
well be us we're wealthy nice people and
we're uh and we're kind of committed to
this and seeing it through so
you know do we think the odds were
relatively high that we would pull it
off no but do we think there was an
opportunity to do the kind of thing that
you're talking about yeah i'd like
others have done it we were not putting
someone on mars right that was not um
it's like okay well people have done
this before and it's just a different
time and maybe now the time is right
for a new company to do something that
you know has been done but uh but better
this goes a little bit to your pixar um
kind of vision sean it's like okay well
you know people sometimes just like okay
well you know what are you gonna do
that's different and why is this you
know what does the world need more the
answer is world doesn't need more
pixar's and so you know saying to you
like oh you don't really need to do that
it's like telling elon musk does the
world really need another car company
and like they kind of downplay the fact
that it's like yeah it's got four wheels
it gets you from point a to point b but
it's all like there's just one
interesting element about it makes it
completely different right it's like
it's the same thing like most ideas that
have been super successful are not
complete new
from whole cloth cut right they're like
they're and i don't like the cliche of
buildings on the shoulders of giants but
it's like like just about everything
that's ever been done is derivative to
some degree it's just based on your
level of abstraction how many steps back
you're willing to go
so it's like okay yeah i can see someone
building something massive here it's
like
i'll get off my rant it's like
so we had facebook
did awesomely well then twitter comes
along and people said oh well that's
just facebook but you have shorter
messages or something like that it's
like facebook with constraints with
lessons yeah facebook comes along it's
like well you can post photos on
facebook why would anyone ever use
instagram that's like facebook with all
the other cool things that i like as
well right no messenger none of that
stuff and then
tick tock comes along it's like well
that's just kind of videos that you can
do on facebook you can do on instagram
you can do on twitter but it's this it's
like just different enough in a
compelling enough way where and it's
still a video social net social based
video app
and lit the world on fire right it's
like so even something as old as video
or as photos
is still not over
it's just not over it's just part of the
kind of the human condition right now
anyway
sean if you go off and want to do
another pixar and if you're ever looking
for an investor that will make a
decision 24 hours by your god what was
that tweet about sean that was on the
left field what are you saying
uh okay so
all my tweets are out of left field so
that's just twitter that's what
twitter's supposed to be right just a
bunch of left field [__] that i'll get
to put in a feed
um
i was watching i don't know what i was
watching i think my nieces were over
they were watching toy story and i was
like twister is amazing pixar's amazing
and i was like why is like i was like i
want to do something amazing this is
literally how my brain works it's like
oh that looks so awesome that's like an
awesome end output i would be so proud
if i had made something like that i bet
i could right like it's this combination
of like
um
seeing something that is really
appealing and then having the delusional
belief that like of course i could do it
if i just tried and
so i just thought it to myself i was
like you know that would be a fun
company to build if you could just make
great stories great movies um and put
them on there into the world like that
would be so fun as a thing if that's
like the thing you did and like
hundreds of millions of people not just
like use your product it's one thing to
use your product it's nothing to like
love it grow up on it and have like you
know like this extreme like
nostalgic emotion around around like
these movies right like if i see you
know for everybody's a little bit
different but for me it's like i don't
know home alone and mighty ducks and
then you know lion king there's like a
couple of movies that just like
uh they meant a lot at the time and they
still mean a lot even though i don't
interact with them
um
so i have because otherwise i'm gonna
forget there's one thing uh i need to
say on this particular episode because
otherwise it'll uh keep me up at night
so i have like a handful of like
frameworks and things i think about the
way i think about the world and this
ties back to uh sean's next trillion
dollar company thing uh pixar which i
think it can be by the way sean just so
you know okay so imagine let's take a
step back i'm on a whiteboard
and the whiteboard
it's the universe of all possible people
everyone on the planet and you draw a
circle with one of your skills so in
sean's case let's say we put copywriting
as one of the skills that he's in the
top one percent or top five percent
whatever number you want to associate
with it and so that's the circle it's
like okay x number of people are at
sean's level um or better and at
copywriting awesome
let's say we draw another circle that's
um we'll call it crypto knowledge is
just how crypto works
and that's a group of people awesome
rarer skill because it's newer there's
fewer people that know how to do that
versus copywriting we can accept that
we'll be a smaller circle
uh what happens though is if you
intersect those two circles and turn
into a venn diagram the number of people
that know copywriting really well and
also know crypto really well is
a hundred times smaller than either of
those circles combined right and this is
we see the same effect like in
standardized tests if you took the sat
or the gre or the gmat there are people
that are really good at english
portion of the test there are people
that are really good at math portion of
the test but the ones that score really
really well are the ones that are
good at both they don't have to be the
best at both because that's the thing
that's actually rare is the combination
of the english and the quant same thing
here so now imagine
so this is what i call it the trillion
dollar venn diagram success right uh i
just made that up but so you draw those
purples of your skills
and say okay well i'm now not like one
in a million i'm one in a billion right
or one in five billion whatever that is
and if you can convert that into some
kind of monetizable business thing or
whatever that's when magic sort of
happens so that's kind of thing number
one it's like what's your thing what are
your skills um and what drives
how much value will that intersection
create is two things
one is
how rare
is that intersection whether it's two
circles or three circles or whatever how
rare is it and then the other one is how
um
how much does it kind of reinforce the
other skills that you already have so
for instance i'm a software developer
that's one of my that's my core skill
i've been programming for like 30 years
now that's my thing deep down inside my
core
if i combine that with i'm going to go
often which i could never do become an
olympic level swimmer let's say
like also very rare the intersection of
that it's like okay well the opportunity
that reveals because the two things are
so unrelated like i don't know how i
would take my ability to build a web app
and intersect it with my like yeah
there's some things i could do i don't
know if that would be that huge
but uh software development is
applicable to lots of if i was going to
be an academic researcher if i was going
to go into music if i was like other
things
um there's a lot more overlap to the
degree that it's like those two they
reinforce each other so software helps
me do this and that helps me do this and
this is one of the reasons uh so my
advice here was as you're picking skills
to acquire
acquire skills that are both rare but
also reinforce things that you're
already exceptional at um that will kind
of drive that kind of that rarity and
that's what drives uh drives the overall
value uh which
kind of brings me to is like and so when
i think of things that i want to learn
it's like okay well this is why i got
into copyright it's like if i can and
copywriting is another form of this is
communicating at scale is what
copywriting is right like it's uh in
usually textual form it's like okay well
i don't know that many software
engineers that can copyright really well
like literally like other than that have
not started companies right it's like
they don't exist but um very rarely do
you get like really really good um
engineers that went off and read six
books on copywriting and took sean's
class that that's not a comment
you are you were a good writing a writer
before you got into this
no
i mean your writing is great and by the
way sean let's let's we got to pimp it
out maven.com
power writing or just go to maven.com
and you see it yeah yeah just go to
maven.commaveen.com i'm on the homepage
starts in two weeks all right so the the
uh
what you said is great i would add one
more circle to that pixar thing by the
way the reason you might pull it off is
because you have a very weird and unique
and related level of skill so yes there
are people that are better
maybe better creatives better animators
better entertaining whatever but they
don't know crypto maybe that's the thing
that unlocks the next trillion dollar
company is entertainment intersect with
crypto it's the netflix for the
blockchain whatever it is right
something like that where two things
combined that never had been put
together in that way before um
the the other circle that i would add
that i think people underestimated so i
tweeted this out right so people i
didn't explain what the tweet is the
tweet was i said the next company i
build is gonna be like a new new age
pixar uh like that like the next pixar
and um i think i i think i would work on
that project for 30 plus like 30 30 plus
years i just keep going with that
company i wouldn't be trying to sell it
or flip it or get out of it or whatever
um
so that was the tweet and then a bunch
of i basically had two reactions one
reaction was
awesome like
where can i sign up how do i work for
this company that's that sounds awesome
i love pixar you could do it and those
are like fans about mfm type of thing or
people who themselves had been thinking
god that would be awesome to create
another like pixar type of company you
know because i love pixar
then there's the other half of people
that were like
what makes you think you could do this
um you know like you know how hard it is
to make a movie you know how expensive
it is you know how how unique you know
steve jobs and you know whatever uh
lasseter and catmol like how rare those
talents were when they came together
that's a once in a generation company
and then other people were like uh one
guy had this amazing burn he was like uh
check
uh aquahire like green checkmark aqua
hired
power writing like course podcast next
pixar and i was like oh thanks that's
pretty solid actually um and so you know
a bunch of people were sort of all in
the same bucket of like this is so hard
this won't work what you you can't do it
that's some version of that
and so the third circle
one is like i'm really great at x i'm
really great at why the third is just i
have the courage to go do a thing and
like um tim ferriss once told this story
he goes i went to a business school
class at harvard business school class i
gave this talk and then the talk i go oh
by the way guys i'm doing this challenge
um
only for you guys you know
whatever
i want to get in touch with either bill
clinton
jennifer lopez or you know some sports
person you know michael jordan or
whatever um if anybody here can connect
me over email with them like you know
just reach out to them and if you get a
hold of them connect me over email i
will buy you two round the world plane
tickets um you know for you could fly
business class for a year uh around the
world anywhere on my dime all right guys
thank you very much and he told that to
one class
and um he's like you know
you have 30 days to complete this
challenge
and then um i think i forgot what it was
it was like he did it to two classes but
he gave a slightly different message in
each the first one he just just said
that 30 days go by nobody did it uh
sorry nobody's completed the challenge
he's like ah what happened you know
turns out nobody even tried the
challenge the perceived difficulty was
so high that nobody did it so in the
next one he told that story and i think
he added a twist which was whoever gets
the closest to it
uh wins
and all of a sudden like everybody tries
and in fact i think somebody did get in
touch and actually successfully
completed the challenge
and he was like he had this principle
which was sort of like you know
everybody wants to fish where everybody
else is fishing because they think it's
so easy to catch fish there he's like in
actuality often it's easy to just go go
catch a fish where the fish actually are
and you you don't have to base it on how
how many people how many other people
you think have tried something or how
what the perceived difficulty is and in
fact sometimes the bigger you go the
easier something can be because nobody
else is even trying to do it and so i
would say like you know this pixar thing
who knows if i'm gonna go do this or
something else i tweet things just
almost to my prototype it's like let me
say this out loud let me see how that
feels if i sleep and to wake up tomorrow
do i want to tweet five more ideas about
that or am i over it it was just a
passing fleeting moment um yeah but but
the the core ingredient i think most
people lack is courage to actually go
and do the thing and i think that's the
the
people put way more emphasis on what
skill am i top one percent and they kind
of they they under credit themselves one
quick one skill you could just have for
free you just got to go it's like at the
santa the deli at the grocery store go
pull the number is yeah i have the
courage to actually go do it like you
know i'm i will go do pull the trigger
on this thing and not wait for other
people to kind of like reinforce that
it's a good idea to me
yeah and this is and i could not agree
more um and so and i think people
conflate sometimes skill versus talent
and they believe they don't have the
talent for entrepreneurship or for
design for programming whatever it is uh
in my mind uh so skill is something
that's learnable that's an easy
definition uh talent is the rate at
which you could acquire a particular
skill so if you have a talent for music
that means you will acquire musical
skills faster than someone that doesn't
have a town for music it doesn't mean
that someone that doesn't have the town
for music can't learn it so they may
have a ceiling as far as how far they
can go fine i get that uh but this
doesn't mean they can't do it and so
one of the big lessons kind of in my in
my life in my professional career is
that most things
are actually skills not talent
mostly like it's like you can start with
zero like i was
i would have been voted least likely to
ever start a company in my entire like
generations of family right like that's
not uh a talent i ever had like when i
um until i went off and did it like
public speaking was not something it's
like oh that that's a skill and you and
then um there's this thing from software
engineering i think it's worth sharing
uh i think some of the best ideas are we
take stuff from other industries and
pull them into this thing and apply it
here in a weird way but in software
engineering there's this thing called
functional decomposition which is take a
problem
be able to articulate well it's a
function that has a set of inputs and an
output and what it's supposed to do
and really all software problems are
being able to take the highest order
function is let's say you want to
grade a possible uh investment based
only on the website it's like oh i'm
going to give you a domain and you're
going to give me a score from 0 to 100
as to how good this is okay well that
function is easy to define like domain
goes in
score from 0 to 100 comes out
what other functions does that function
need in order to pull that off it's like
okay i want a function that looks at the
domain and looks at the level of seo
they have that's one layer down the
person that's writing the seo function
goes down levels like i'm going to look
at the on-page seo and see how good
they're doing at meta tags and h1 titles
and i'm going to look at the off page
seo then their link acquisition and that
kind of stuff that's it's like so if you
roll it all down
and you go down far enough individual
functions at the atomic level are so
simple as to be trivial
what matters is the fact that you were
able to abstract it down that simple
thing right so most things uh can be
broken down that way so so if you look
at oh i want to become someone that can
give a talk in front of 25 000 people on
a stage
that seems like an insurmountable task
for someone like me that's never done
that and that's not my that might not my
thing it's like oh well what does that
involve number one you have to have
kind of overcome i didn't have like
stage fright i had severe stage anxiety
right stage fright is like oh there's a
ship that's gonna come down from space
and just suck you up because you were so
bad
and stage anxiety is like
man i wish a spaceship would come down
and send me off the stage right now i
want to get off um
so there's that like don't you don't
pass out on stage and then there's the
oh
you learn about storytelling you learn
about writing you learn about slide
design you learn about humor and i did
all those things right read books took
classes on all those components of
public speaking in an aggregate
i'm okay now right like i can do that
and you then it's practice and you do it
over time so anyway
my point here is uh startups whatever
skill and startups are a skill figure
out what set of skills you need to
acquire some you'll be good at acquiring
because you have the talent the other
one you're just gonna have to grind it
out more than others may but it's doable
it's a doable thing one question that i
have if i can do it anyone can do it
that's my point i love that so sean
kind of
sean kind of added this thing to your uh
your event diagram of like just people
brave enough to get started and
would you add another thing like when
with the hustle we sold in year four or
five and i'm i don't regret it i'm very
happy with that but i actually like we
lo i looked at the numbers this year and
i was like oh wow we would have made
like
maybe like it's it was close to the
point where like you could have
potentially next year made more revenue
that year than all the revenues uh
combined um and i'm like whoa that's
kind of crazy like i again i'm happy
with it but
like real value like i guess for me i
was like real value was created in year
like five six seven eight of course you
probably could say like
when you're in your five seven eight
you're like oh wow it's really created
in 10 11 12. but um
do you think that um what portion of
hubspot and your success
has been well i'm just really i'm just
willing to shut up and focus on this for
20 years as opposed to uh you actually
being amazing or good at product and
marketing and things like that
um yeah here's how i think about it i
think the outcome is a combination of
like dreaming really big
and like iterating really small and
having tight feedback feedback loops so
the dream really big is you have to have
something that can someday translate in
it doesn't have to be as clear of vision
as you know shawn is kind of laid out as
far as oh it's going to be
pixar for the new generation um but you
have to kind of have start with
something roughly big in mind at least
at some level but then it really comes
down to the iteration right it's um i
think and others have demonstrated this
through data is that the quality output
is almost i won't say always but
frequently a function of the number of
iterations not the quality of the you
know people's for instance so one of the
common examples that's thrown out is and
i've heard it with a pottery class or a
photography class but it's like oh one
set of students divided class and half
uh let's say it's a photography class uh
one set of students it's like okay every
day you have to submit a photo for the
next 30 days while this class is running
the other one is like at the end of the
30 days you're going to submit your best
photo
and then your grade is going to be based
on the quality of that best photo the
first class is like as long as you
submit a photo every day you're going to
get an a at the end of the 30 days the
other one is like as long as your is
eight quality material that photo is
going to win and what's been proven out
across disciplines is that the class
that did the multiple iterations had a
better output than the one was trying to
solve for quality like the
arguably the first one's like all they
really had to do was like submit a photo
it didn't have to be like world-class
quality it's not the best i could do but
just by virtue of doing it they're going
to make it better and make it better at
the end of the 30 days they produced a
better photo and they produced a better
clay pot if it was a pottery class than
the other one that was solving for
quality and they were like too much in
their heads trying to say oh i'm gonna
do the best i can do like no just do it
repeatedly
but the key to that it has to be
meaningful iteration if you're just
iterating and doing the same thing
you're not learning anything there's no
feedback loop then the iterations have
no value but if you're if you have a
tight feedback loop like i'm going to do
this thing and i immediately get
response back that tells me whether i
got better or got worse
that is amazingly like powerful to be
able to do that and compound it over
time so so i think my
i'm not that special candidly it's like
i'm willing to grind it out more than
people that are smarter and i'm a little
bit smarter than people that are willing
to work grind it out that's my venn
diagram
that's awesome
have you you've probably seen this or
maybe you guys have done this but
there's this group of like consultants
that created this thing called the
marshmallow challenge which they go to a
company and they give you like a bunch
of um sticks
uh one marshmallow some tape and like a
string or something like that have you
seen this star mesh
i think i have yeah
but i'll kind of summarize for this for
sure yeah yeah those who have it
basically they give they give you this
these set of um tools and they say okay
your goal the game is you need to get a
marshmallow
the winning team is going to have a
marshmallow like as high above this
table as you can so build your tower as
high as you can if you can whoever gets
the highest marshmallow whoever's tower
has the highest marshmallow at the end
wins we're right we're gonna stop the
clock after 30 minutes we're going to
say hands up and you know your
marshmallow whoever's marshmallow is
standing the highest wins okay good good
so they go and they do this test with
like a bunch of different types of
people they do it with consultants they
do it with like kind of doctors and they
do it with you know engineers they do it
with um whoever creatives like ad agency
types and they're trying to see okay
which group is going to perform the best
at a challenge like this
and basically across the board what they
found is that uh they suspected maybe
engineers are gonna do the best and the
engineers do on average do a little bit
better than than others but not by much
they actually are all pretty horrible at
it and i think like you know whatever
80-90 of the groups at the end of the
challenge their marshmallow is on the
ground it is fallen over it never even
um you know got up at all like if you
had just put it if you're just taking
like you know two sticks and put up one
marshmallow on top you would have won
the challenge um and the reason why is
and they did this test with kids and
kids actually are phenomenal at this
kids on average will beat the adults at
this game and why is that well because
what happened is they would give the
project to the adults and the adults
would spend the first five minutes like
delegating roles like okay you're going
to be the person who does the planning
you're going to be the one who you work
on the sticks and the bottom structure
we're going to do this over here then
they would just like kind of draw out
like okay let's do a tp no let's do a
ladder let's do this a cube or shape or
whatever
and they would do all this and at the
very end they would try to stick the
marshmallow on and what they don't
realize is the marshmallow is a lot
heavier than it looks and it will
outweigh the sticks and it'll all fall
over
and
because they're doing that thing where
they wait on the very end to like ship
the final good product they don't even
realize we're the flaw in their plan
until like it's too late essentially
whereas what kids will do is kids will
immediately grab the thing they'll stick
the marshmallow on and it's like if the
kids don't eat the marshmallow the
marshmallow will like get into the
structure very quickly and they'll see
oh it falls over okay it falls over that
means we need to iterate we need to do
things differently than we would have
otherwise assumed and that like one
lesson i've done at pretty much every
company i've ever started because it's
the only way i can get engineers and
designers who by nature are often like
sort of like perfectionist or quality
and like they in their associate they in
their mind associate the longer we work
at this the better the quality will be
before we ship it and i'm always like
dude let's ship it today let's see how
bad it sucks and then let's remove some
suck from it and like tomorrow it'll
suck a little less and then tomorrow
it'll suck a little less again
and the best way i've been able to drive
this point home is to give them the
marshmallow challenge and not just like
watch the video watch the ted talk it's
like no
go fail at this so that you taste defeat
and then you will actually learn this
lesson
dude that's like the greatest ceo thing
that you've ever done that's a good one
that's a really good one is to make
people do this and then make them watch
the ted talk that's like that's a really
good leadership tactic i'm 100 gonna
steal that one day
yeah it's it's an awesome one um
all right i don't know we went kind of
long i don't know if we're good to keep
going or not but
ben's telling me uh wrap up but uh
but uh darmesh this is awesome man i
love having you around are you uh
you um
the last time you were on was like a
year ago i think
and i've been like
i've been like begging you i'm like man
just come on and so we messaged him
today and he goes i'll just come on
today i was like all right cool are you
uh
i actually i have a quick question what
you know people ask me about selling to
hubspot and they're like has it been
good from a creative perspective it's
been awesome you guys have it like we
haven't been told a thing on like what
we can and cannot do of course i don't
think we do anything where anyone would
ever tell us you can't do that but uh
it made it darmas do you ever get
complaints about anything we say that's
what i was gonna ask that's what i was
gonna ask is there anything that like
so far i guess there's nothing that's
crossed the line because we've not heard
a thing but like it we've it's been
crazy how productive uh this
relationship has been i did not think
that because you know
people say one thing and the reality is
different but it's not been that way
that's been pretty cool
yeah thank you i'm glad uh glad that
it's working out in your teams
you folks have been kind of great for
hubspot um and i know this keeps you up
at night in terms of valuation i've
thought about that a lot um
probably not as much as you have but
at the time i
i would not
beat yourself up over it i think it was
a fair deal i i don't know that and even
at that just so you know even at that
price uh and not nothing to do with you
but like it was a board level discussion
we had this like okay was do we really
want to yes not that it wasn't worth
that but was it worth that to us at the
time because it was a relatively new um
new thing that we were doing but um i
think there's some perfect for both
sides but yeah for sure i think there's
a world i think there's a world where in
one to three years the podcast alone is
worth more than the deal
yes i definitely see that yes um yeah
but in the same way kind of when we can
kind of wrap on this is that when we
were talking early in the beginning of
the episode around kind of compensation
as being just one of the kind of
dimensions of value
in a acquisition
the kind of the valuation that you get
the price tag is just one dimension of
value then the rest of it is how happy
are you how happy is the team did you
meet people that will kind of
uh you will enjoy working within your
future years are you are your future
co-founders that kind of thing it's like
uh we know that this is not forever we
like we know that going in with uh even
with people we hire uh but especially
with m a but um
yeah but hopefully the in aggregate um
you know spot delivers a bunch of value
that's my uh pitch for why it's okay to
join hubspot if you're ever uh out there
looking but
no it was awesome well thank you this is
awesome sean what do you think yeah
great episode and i'm glad you used our
line against us i i he emailed us
something i was like oh you should come
back on sometime which is like the
sometime is like one of the most
dangerous words in the english language
yeah because it's like you think it's
soon and in reality it's never um and
you'd pulled a great move which was what
we talked about which is like forget
scheduling stuff like either i want to
do it and if i if i can do it right now
let's do it right now and if not like
let's not schedule it for the future
because
just because we didn't want to do it
right now and you were like how about
today and we were like all right let's
do it let's do it perfect
and i intentionally made it um like open
it's like okay i knew when my last
meeting was it's like any time after
this so it's not even like oh like i
could have made it work this afternoon
but i was only available for the small
windows like no any time between 2 p.m
and midnight if you get
[Music]
it's a lot of fun thank you for coming
on
all right thanks for having me
[Music]
you